what does a
disciplined life look like doing what
you're supposed to do
what if i want to lay on the couch and
eat cheetos
and watch soap operas that's
that's not that doesn't feel like
discipline do you think you're supposed
to do that
well you know you could argue from a
sort of
uh meaning of life perspective that
perhaps happiness is the most important
and if it makes me happy
uh perhaps that's um if it's fulfilling
of course eating cheetos and watching
some properties is fulfilling for nobody
whatsoever
next question but there's something
about discipline that's
more than that which is um
like the rigor of habit right you
you wake up early in the morning all the
time
uh what is it jordan peterson talks
about make your bed
it's one place where you probably agree
with jordan
people ask me if i make my bed i don't
oh and i never know there's a
disagreement with jordan there we go
you know when i was uh younger before i
was married
i didn't make my bed because i had one
sleeping bag on it and i would get out
of the sleeping bag there was nothing to
make
yeah now i'm married and
i can't make my bed because my wife's in
my bed so i don't make my bed
okay so what in your life
maybe we can talk about the one that's
most publicly facing
which is uh you wake up at four o'clock
or around four o'clock in the morning
you post uh
on social media a a picture of your
watch
it being early just to remind people
that uh
you uh are man of your word
what's that about what's the philosophy
of the four o'clock
what role does that play in a
disciplined life for you
okay from that perspective what role it
plays is getting a jump on the day
and i when you wake up early and you get
a jump on the day and you've got your
workout done and you've got a little bit
of
a little bit of work done yeah by the
time
normal people are getting up that's a
win
that's a psychological win and it's not
just a psychological one it's an actual
win
it's an actual win so that feels great
it doesn't feel great maybe when your
alarm clock goes off but by
eight o'clock in the morning and you've
already accomplished
some of the major tasks that you have
some of the most painful tasks that you
have for the day
you're off to a great start and it's
gonna feel great
you